tras el repliegue de la otan china
aparece como principal aliado de las
nuevas autoridades de kabul con el
propósito de mantener cierta estabilidad
en la región gobierno afgano y
organizaciones internacionales confían
en beijing para liderar la llegada de
ayuda humanitaria después de liderar la
creación del grupo de países vecinos de
afganistán china anunció el envío de 30
millones de dólares en alimentos y
vacunas contra el cob y 19 al tiempo que
acusa a eeuu de desatender sus
responsabilidades respecto del pueblo
afgano luego de 20 años de invasión
eeuu se exige a otros países que
respeten los derechos humanos pero evita
mencionar sus abusos de los derechos
humanos en afganistán y otros lugares
mientras eeuu oculta su responsabilidad
en el causa actual de afganistán
especula y hace comentarios
irresponsables sobre los esfuerzos
constructivos de otros países
especialmente los vecinos de afganistán
washington y kabul de momento no
mantienen lazos diplomáticos oficiales
la salida del primer avión de pasajeros
incluyendo estadounidenses desde que
eeuu se retiró del país fue
entendimiento mediante las autoridades
qataríes
de momento occidente no da el paso hacia
el reconocimiento del gobierno talibán
waliur reconocerán al gobierno afgano y
los talibanes buscan apoyo y legitimidad
internacional eso dependerá de lo que
hagan no sólo de lo que digan entrar
distintos países se han mostrado
pesimistas ante la composición del
gobierno interino afgano ya que una
decena de sus miembros están en las
listas negras de las agencias
estadounidenses y de naciones unidas-
mientras que imágenes de mujeres
reprimidas durante manifestaciones y
periodistas torturados dan la vuelta al
mundo